So we have the settings icon where we have to set up, in settings you will have the option
of academics.
By clicking on academics, you will have various options defined in which you have to work.
Sir, is this much clear at the end of all of you?
Yes, it is clear.
Now what we have to do is create a timetable, so the first step for timetable is to define
the subjects in the system, after defining the subjects, you have to define the subject
class mapping.
So first of all, we have to define the subjects in the system, you have the first option,
now I don't have any subject in the system, you have the option at the top, add subject.
You will click on this, I am creating a subject, English, subject name, then there is a unique
code of the subject, it may be that the name of the subject is common, but there is a code
that defines it.
I have put the code, three digit code ENG, then it has an assessment model, scholastic
subject, course scholastic subject.
Scholastic subjects are basically those subjects in which we have to do marks entry.
For example, like your GK, your primary classes, GK, which are your small classes, in that
case your course is scholastic or in the discipline, basically you use grading criteria for it,
teachers enter grade.
So we have created four assessment models.
Can I interrupt a little?
Yes, tell me.
The subject name is English, it will be everyone's, English is in 7th, and will this subject code
be different for 6th and 7th?
No, no, no, no, it's the same.
This subject code defines your subject, it will not define your class.
It will not define your subject.
It can be general knowledge, general knowledge has to be used completely, GK has to be used
completely, so that's for it.
I have done the assessment model scholastic.
Sir, we have the option to define class and stream.
There are some subjects, we want that when we create mapping, it should only show in
these particular classes, not in all of them.
So in that case, you can map a particular class here.
For example, there is a subject that I want that when I create mapping for 5th and 6th
classes, it should only display to me.
It should not display in other classes, it should not be able to add.
So in that case, I can select this in a particular class.
For example, my English is for everyone, so I will not select a particular class, I will
simply add it.
This is my subject added.
In this way, you can add subjects according to your classes, or you can add data of subjects
Excuse me, ma'am.
Ma'am, can we skip the code?
Is it necessary to give?
Ma'am, this is necessary to give.
You can add anything according to your classes.
For example, I used ENG for English.
In this way, code is considered a mandatory field.
In our system, code is mandatory.
You can add anything according to your classes.
You can use HIN for Hindi, you can use MAT for Math, kind of.
This was the subject.
Ma'am, is there any query in the subject?
No, ma'am.
It's okay.
Okay, sir.
One more thing I want to clear here.
The subjects that we have created.
It is possible that later you have to change something in the name of the subject.
You feel that I have to change its name.
So in that case, if you have only created the subject, I have not added it in any class
So I can edit it till then.
I can edit whatever I want to edit in it.
But if I have added it in the mapping, then I can't edit it from here.
Then I can only change its display name from the mapping.
I can't change the name of the subject.
Okay, sir.
Then we have created the subjects.
Then we have the created subjects.
We have to map them in their respective class.
That is the option in the subject class mapping.
You can call it subject course mapping and subject class mapping.
You have the first option in this.
Add new subject class mapping.
You will click on this.
Then you will define the class.
You are making it for the fifth class.
There is an option that we can multi-select.
You feel that in fifth, sixth, seventh, I have common subjects.
So you can create three classes together.
Class fifth, by default, it will select the stream.
And by default, it will select all the sections.
I will create a single section now.
Then after that, you have to add the details of the subject.
That means in class fifth, you have the subjects.
You are defining the subjects.
Okay, I added the subject.
I have the list of the subjects that I have created there.
I will type and select according to the dropdown.
Now the assessment model that I added there,
my assessment model is there.
Then you have the subject type.
What is the subject type basically?
There are some subjects for some classes
which are optional subjects or additional subjects.
It is not general.
It is not common for all the students.
So now English is common for all the students.
So all the students in this class,
I have to apply this subject from here.
There is no such option that two kids have it,
three kids don't have it.
So now we will do it in general.
But in case, like in class fifth, sixth,
GK came, drawing came, Punjabi.
So all these subjects are optional.
So in that case, you can use it optionally.
If you do it optionally from here,
then what will happen from here?
You define it in the subject mapping that it is an optional subject.
All the students will not like it.
And then you will go ahead and define it in the next step.
Okay, for now, I will just add it as a general from here.
Okay, this is my mapping created
in which I have added one subject.
Okay, the rest you had the option from here.
You add more subjects in it.
Other than this, all the subjects that will be there,
you will keep adding subjects from here.
Okay, next subject.
In this way, your whole list will be created.
How many subjects are coming in this class?
Okay, sir, is there any other query in this part?
I will explain it to you.
I will do it.
Okay.
Then now what happens with us,
we have created the class,
in which we have defined the subjects.
Now basically, in this class,
who is the class teacher?
Who is its coordinator?
Is the subject's corresponding subject teacher?
So, we have to define that.
Class 5th.
In class 5th A,
who is my class teacher?
You have a list of employees.
Right?
The ID of the employees that we have created.
You will define it from here.
For example, this is my class teacher.
So, I have set it here as a class teacher.
You can assign a coordinator
to any other employee.
Okay.
In class teacher, we have an option
that we can map a single employee.
Because a class teacher is always single for a class.
But if you want to do multiple,
then you can use the coordinator.
From here, you can map all the coordinators
for this class.
And one more thing,
the one whom we map the class teacher and coordinator,
he has all the subjects of a particular class.
Okay.
So, he has access to all those subjects.
Now, you feel that you have to give
a single subject to a teacher.
For example, if he is a subject teacher,
then from here, the subject teacher is mapped.
The same subject teacher also has an option
that you can set multiple subject teachers.
Okay.
This was our teacher mapping.
Now, there is one more thing.
As I told you,
by chance, you feel that
I have to define the name of the subject
in some other way.
So, in that case, this is the display name.
The display name that you will give,
in the future,
like you will do marks entry,
which is visible at the end of the student to the teacher,
then that display name will appear
which you will give the display name here.
Okay, sir.
If I edit this normal from here,
just a moment.
I have done this single subject.
Okay.
Now, I will edit this.
So, I have this teacher map in this.
Okay.
It is showing you
which subject is included in the English subject.
Sir, I have just created this.
Right now, I have not assigned this to anyone
because this is what I have done to show you.
This is the display name that I have added, ENG.
So, now, in the future,
I will be using the name of ENG everywhere.
Okay.
Sir, there is an icon.
We have this edit.
After creating every mapping,
whatever changes you want to make further,
you can make changes from here.
Okay.
Then, we have the option
to assign by default.
All the subjects added,
general subjects added,
you will select them from here.
After selecting them from here,
if you assign them,
all the students will get them in the class.
Right now, I am not doing it
because right now,
we are making it according to the test.
So, I am not assigning the students.
Okay, sir.
Let's move forward with some doubts.
Okay.
Okay, sir.
I will tell you one thing.
Do you have the criteria
for optional subjects?
The criteria for optional subjects?
Yes.
Absolutely.
Okay, sir.
Then, I will explain that once.
For example,
the subject that I have,
it is an optional subject.
Okay.
Or it can be an additional,
a vocational subject.
You can set it according to that.
Okay.
Then, you can simply edit it.
After that,
now, you have defined this optional subject.
But, from here,
you can set it in bulk.
All the students can use this subject.
Right.
Right now, this is an optional subject.
So, not everyone will use it.
Some students will use it.
Okay.
So, how can we use it?
For that,
you have a separate option
for the assigned subject.
Okay.
We assign the optional subjects
from here.
You select the class.
You simply go to the class.
You get the list of the students of that class.
Okay.
Now, which of these students
do you want to assign the English optional subject to?
So, you will select from here.
The students whom you want to assign,
you have seen that.
I don't want to give this optional subject to the students.
After selecting,
you have the option,
assign subject.
You have created that optional there.
Optional.
And, here, you will get that subject.
Okay.
By adding the subject,
as soon as you add it,
this subject will only be assigned to those students
whom you have selected.
Not everyone will get it.
Option number 3.
They have told us about the whole class.
The whole class will be assigned from there, ma'am.
What we have done from here.
Subject class mapping.
I will tell you again.
You have made it as a general map here.
Look.
What you have to do with the subject here.
Instead of optional,
you have to make it a general map.
As soon as you add the subject,
you can make it a general map
and assign it directly from here.
Click and assign from here.
I am not doing it now.
All the students will get it.
If you assign it normally,
all the students will get the subject.
Okay.
you have the option from outside too.
You have the same icon from here too.
Select and assign.
So, all the students will get the subject.
Yes.
Okay.
Then,
this was the part to create the subject.
To create the subject class mapping.
Right.
Now, according to this,
we will define our timetable.
Okay.
For that,
you will have the option of timetable.
You will do that much part.
After that,
from here,
we will define the timetable
that in one class,
this is the subject,
this is the teacher,
how to map them in the future.
Okay.
So, for example,
I will create a timetable.
Add new timetable.
Okay.
You have selected the class.
I have a single class in mapping.
Okay.
So,
you are making a timetable
of a single class.
After that,
add new schedule.
Okay.
Now, you will define in this.
You will get the lecture number.
Lecture number 1.
Lecture number 2.
Lecture number 1,
when your class is going to start,
it is the start time,
the end time.
Just a minute.
Okay.
So we will continue here.
Okay sir.
Okay.
we will add schedule.
So, in schedule,
we have lecture number 1.
Okay.
The fifth class.
lecture number 1.
Okay?
When does the class start?
For example,
my class starts at 8 pm.
exact start 8 a.m.. 8 to 8.45 is my first lecture. 8.40 a.m. then you can save this
schedule or you can add more lectures after this which you defined as second lecture.
First lecture is my 8 to 8.40. Then automatically lecture 2 starts from 8.40. From 8.40 till
9.20 till my second lecture. Can you tell me sir till when is your second lecture?
Till 9.20.
Till 9.20. Now I am creating only two lectures. I have created two lectures, saved the schedule.
They are asking for all the schedules. Sir, you have to add all the timings.
From lecture 3 till 9.20, tell me sir till when is this first third?
Till 10 o'clock.
Then for your fourth lecture?
Till 4th lecture.
Till 10.40.
When do you get break after this?
After 10.40, break is for 10 minutes.
So this is your break in lecture 5 right?
Yes, for 10 minutes, till 10.50.
Till 10.50.
Then your lecture 6?
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
how is the subject?
You have to add the subject here.
Add the name of the subject.
There is a single subject there.
Add the subject.
Employee, for English,
I have mapped two teachers for the subject.
I have selected.
I will push, I have the subject.
I will remove it.
You can also remove it from here.
I clicked on it.
Subject, English, employee's name.
Push.
You have mapped the teacher for this.
If you feel there is someone else on Tuesday,
then the same option will remain.
You feel you have to define the break from here.
You can define the break from here.
You can also run two subjects at the same time.
There is also an option for another.
If there is someone else here,
then you can add that too.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
you have come properly.
Simply define the subject.
Define the subject.
And push from there.
At that time period, there is a break.
Click on it.
If you toggle on this break, then that break will be applied.
Same push and remove.
Both options remain.
In this part,
how to create a timetable in a query?
Bro,
I don't know.